we have a voicemail number it's 2192
david p here's another idea about the
entire Trump didn't know that he was
signing an order to put feet Bannon on
the National Security Council story
here's a suggestion about what the truth
might be from a viewer hey David stray
from Maryland I'm calling about a trump
saying that he didn't know that he put
then and on that council and what I
think is why he signed that is just
because of his reactionary nature and
that we've seen over the course of his
campaign and all of that that um he knew
that he was putting Bannon on but then
after everyone making fun of it on SNL
and all that which of course we know
Trump loves his TV that uh he's he's
saying that he didn't know just because
everyone's talking about it yeah our
thanks days that's a good idea which is
we reported Trump had no clue what he
was signing when he puts the abandoned
on the National Security Council it's
possible that he did know and then after
there was so much in the media which
maybe Trump was surprised by or didn't
get criticizing him for having put
Bannon on there he decided to say oh you
know what I didn't even read it I just
signed it without reading it interesting
hypothesis I don't know that we'll ever
really know but but quite an idea
presented there there are really no
scenarios that make Trump look good here
though is what makes him look slightly
less bad and I actually don't know what
the answer is there on the bonus show
today we will hear about Rachel's wild
adventure to South America I will tell
you what percentage of Australian
Catholic priests have been accused of
sexually abusing children think of a
number and now double it well now maybe
that's too high I guess it depends what
number you first bought it well it will
expose the number on the bonus show Pat
confused by my math right now and the
david pakman show coffee is now
available we will discuss that on the
bonus show as well david pakman.com
slash membership sign up today get
instant access coupon code if you want
to discount you don't have to take the
discount but if you want to discount use
the coupon code i voted 17